[Musik]
denn vor königin und das mache vor stark
höchstens 25
csu
aus worden
in merkels avantgarde
es war einmal eine bernerin die königin
wurde weil sie einen prinzen geheiratet
und mit ihm einen sohn gezeugt hatte die
geschichte begann vor zehn jahren und
siehst war auch wenn sie wie ein märchen
klingt
was ist geworden aus dem traum von
katharina paolo hänni als königin in
kamerum zu leben und wie beeinflusst der
glaube und schwarze magie ihre ehe davon
handelt dieser film
[Musik]
das steht für dich
total wasche ich
möchte ganz
währung gesehen und was verglichen
dass die schüler lothar fleisch ist
die ratten fangen sie rund ums haus
noch vor jahren hatte die familie am
hungertuch heute haben sie genug zu
essen sie züchten im eigenen garten
früchte und gemüse
das sich sicher
dass da hier die tablette durchaus es
hat dazu
und hier immer eine frau show dass sie
die beste zitrone sei zwar schwierig
aber die fast so viel saft
liebe die ihr vor
europa das da hier ist zitronengras
bei unserem jüngsten besuchte merkel
will dass masserey und katharina sich
ein wenig aus dem wege gehen
spannungen wie es sie immer wieder
gegeben hat in dieser
schweizerisch-amerikanischen beziehung
die so begonnen hatte
2005 entdeckte die damals arbeitslose
verkäuferin im internet ein bild von
prinz marcel
sie verliebte sich in den kameruner ohne
ihn je getroffen zu haben gegenüber
bekannten zeigte sie mit stolz ihre
frisch gedruckte visitenkarte als
königin
[Musik]
am flughafen von kamerun fielen sich die
beiden zum ersten mal in die arme
im abgelegenen hoch war wurde die
bernerin begeistert empfangen
mitgenommen hatte sie all ihren staates
inklusive pensionskassen geld
[Musik]
einen kult und polygamie gehören hier
zum alltag machte ihnen klar dass sie
wirklich einmal eine profilen der frauen
sind
das sind die einzigste grippe am palast
der königin beim kac steht die skulptur
des verstorbenen königs robert in
schicke er hatte 150 frauen und über 750
nachkommen einer davon ist masse
der aktuelle könig masse landeshaupt
bruder verheiratete die bernerin mit dem
prinzen
anvertrauen nahmen auch katharinas
elternteil denen bald klar wurde dass
sie schwiegersohn ii könig sein wird er
bleibt ein prinz ohne palast mit einer
frau die sich weiterhin königin legt
[Applaus]
zehn monate später kam sohn sky zur welt
das glück schien perfekt doch in der
beziehung zeigten sich bereits erste
risse
ich selber habe keine opfer mehr aber
sie hat probleme weil sie mich überhaupt
nicht verstellt
sich vergisst dass ich ein afrikaner bin
und sie vergisst dass ich ein adliger
wenig
in der abgeschiedenheit wo das leben ein
tägliche existenzkampf ist schmiedete
katharina grosse pläne
[Musik]
zwei jahre später fünf bewaffnete männer
überfielen die kleinfamilie und raubten
sie aus
was aber vergitterte danach den eingang
und legte sich eine pistole zu
traumatisiert vom überfall begann zu
trinken
immer wieder musste katharina ein spital
alleine wegen malaria ein dutzend mal
sie hatte wärme und ein maßstab sie fast
an blutarmut
dann
ein weiteres drama mit ihrem sohn
flüchtete sie in die schweiz aus angst
vor ihrem mann
denkt
also aggressiv immer verbal
trotzdem zog sie ein jahr später zurück
nach kamerun katharina hoffte dass sich
ihr prinz gebessert hätte sie füllte
einen container mit gebrauchten möbeln
um sie nach afrika zu schicken
heute lebt sie nun also wieder an jenem
ort wo sie dem glück so nahe war aber
auch der verzweiflung einige ihrer
vorhaben verschwinden buchstäblich im
meter hohen gras so auch das geplante
hotel
dass eine grüne fertigmachen
discounter und mehrere platten 36 ist
haben wir oft oder gesetzt und das immer
machen ist
das protein immer
damit gerechnet dass meine tochter macht
erobert hofer dach frühstücks terrassa
machen mag den wunderschönen
katharina trotz allen schwierigkeiten
doch der geldmangel bleibt ihr ständiger
begleiter
und so nähert sich die familie von dem
was der boden hergibt ohne festes
einkommen
wir hatten eine längere pechsträhne
ich bin immer sehr beschäftigt mit dem
bau des hotels und der feldarbeit habe
ich auch noch anderes zu tun aber mit
sicherheit wird auch das heute noch
fertig gebaut nicht mein sohn wird das
fertig bauen sondern nicht selber
immerhin das gästehaus ist fast fertig
aber eben nur fast
das gebäude bröckelt vor sich hin wo
bleibt die meiste zeit hindurch
ungenutzt für sky ein idealer tomo glas
die spielkameraden des achtjährigen sind
die haustiere
[Musik]
das
kommt wie gut es hängt aber hinauf viel
kürzer übersetzt anders kennt wie in
europa unser körper spieler die werte
einfach bruch der helfer die mit
wasser
abwasser wollen und dabei und habe den
aufgaben unter die sauce
sky kann zwei sprachen mit der mutter
spricht berndeutsch mit dem vater
französisch er geht inzwischen in die
zweite klasse
gar nicht so
[Musik]
jeden morgen fährt die königin ihren
kleinen prinzen und die knapp zehn
kilometer entfernte schule das auto kann
sich der familie leisten weil katharinas
mutter ab und zu etwas geld schickt
der kleine besucht in der ortschaft bank
ag eine katholische privatschule
umgerechnet 100 franken kostet das
schulgeld pro jahr
seine mitschüler nennen ihn den weißen
[Musik]
die klasse um fast 80 schülerinnen und
schüler die lehrerin hat sich verspätet
der lärm luft den schuh direktor aus dem
plan
nicht nur die pädagogischen methoden
sind dann diese privatschule etwas
speziell
das sind zwei welten und die gruppe der
bis 1800 schüler das ist durchaus
schäden
sind newsletter mit wochen fit war es
die zu bringen das sich heute besser aus
hier auf dem schulgrundstück craybas
[Musik]
die lehrerin kam dann doch noch zum
unterricht
sky sei ein guter schüler sagt sie uns
nicht weit entfernt befindet sich in
einer verwinkelten gassen ein kleines
privatradio hier moderiert der print
seit kurzem wöchentlich eine sendung
da spaß überwiegt den massener macht den
job nicht des geldes wegen
die sendung finanzieren jedoch kleine
sponsoren aus der umgebung es geht
langsam aufwärts aber im moment hat das
rad ja nicht viel geld
seit einiger zeit haben die biostrom es
sei denn diebe hätten wieder mal die
isolatoren geklaut fernsehen und
internet die neuzeit ist im busch
angekommen
[Musik]
inzwischen interessieren sich weit über
600 facebook-freunde für die abenteuer
der schweizerin
in afrika
zwei jahren völlig gaga
sieht das anders sieht das die sonne -
euro tisch es kommt ja ob er hat strom
gemacht also mit ansehen ist gut aber
eben träume zu realisieren ist schwierig
immer einsamen buschland wo jeder
vorbeifahrende lastwagen zum ereignis
wird ausgerechnet hier versuchte
katharina einen kiosk zu eröffnen
am anfang ist mit offenen armen
empfangen hat ist jetzt unter mensch die
fähigkeit diesen größte verantwortung
wer ist das diese dorfchef wo vorher
aber so fröhlich jetzt trauern freese
dass sie nicht süß kommen also eine
quelloffene zu schaffen und einfach
probiert ist aber sehr schwarz machen
das klingt im laderaum der dorfchef und
nachbar wohnte einen speerwurf von der
königin entfernt
zerfressen von neid beanspruchte er
einen teil ihres landes sagen die paulus
diese zusammengebundenen este hat der
feind angebracht und sie bedeuten krieg
katharina bietet uns ihn nicht zu
besuchen der nachbar sei gefährlich denn
er betreibe schwarze magie
und
tastatur
der streit mit den nachbarn belastet
dass sie leben was sie im februar dieses
jahres wirken sich die beiden sogar
trennen aber sie glauben dass die
beziehungsprobleme nicht hausgemacht
sind vielmehr seien böse kräfte im spiel
der nachbar und durch schiff habe die
familie verhext
ich bat katharine in die schweiz zu
gehen damit ich die probleme hier lösen
kann und
das um gegen ihre feinde zu kämpfen
sie werden gewinnen
ich gewinne immer
hat der konflikt und braucht für mich
und für ihn ganz in rosa triumphierte
paterson
reagiert aber das ranking etwa schläft
wenig oder
folglich methodik
und inhalt von der sport tag war er mit
trend
das will sie nicht begreifen ich will
ihr leben und das meines kindes besteht
nicht
wenn ich nach hause komme und sauer bin
dann denkt sie dass ich 1000 biere intus
habe das ist nicht so
kann ich mich kaum noch auf die arbeit
konzentrieren ich denke ständig daran
sie um ein kind zu beschützen das so
schutzlos ist
zum glück sind in barolo es noch einige
leute woge sind kommen diese auch besuch
wirken alle probleme in den hintergrund
[Musik]
katharina lässt sich nichts anmerken
aber sie hat wegen der probleme bereits
einen entscheid gefällt zusammen mit
sohn sky will sie in die schweiz gehen
marcel ist damit einverstanden nur
erkennt die ganze wahrheit nicht
die frühschicht schweiz und belegen auf
afrika aber du hast dass die website
ist das nicht ein vertrauensbruch
für us airways nicht wie die jetzige
situation
reagieren und wir geben das ver klare
iwf oder zigbee
sie hat angst angst vor ihrem
unberechenbar mann und angst vor dem
unheimlichen nachbarn in einigen tagen
wird sie in die schweiz zurückreisen und
weiß nicht ob sie je hierher
zurückkehren wird
anfangs herbst 2014 am wohnort von
katharinas mutter im bernischen kehrsatz
seit bald vier monaten wurden sie nun
bei margarita hänni und inzwischen ist
klar das auf und ab geht weiter
katharina wieder zurück zum wasser der
streit ums land wo der inzwischen
gerichtlich zu ihren gunsten entschieden
sie dürfen ihr ganzes land behalten und
um ihre probleme zu lösen hat sie eine
ziemlich überraschende idee
und das war nicht objektiv europäische
arzt löse logisch wies und das nicht
immer optimal funktioniert und die denke
wenn man nur verstehen was man
afrikanische problem lösen dass mir
besser schlag halte das kann genau wie
die scheitere welches ein herzenswunsch
ist dass sie das so gar
nicht nach einem jahr
das geht nicht
doch die erwünschte zweitfrau ist
bereits auserkoren
sie heißt angel und arbeitet als
marktfrau wir treffen die 40 jährige in
der hafenstadt douala in kamerun
angel ist geschieden und hat ein kind
wie massener stammt sie aus dem hochland
dort lebte sie auch das ehepaar paolo
können
das problem ist folgendes wir reden hier
in einer afrikanischen kultur hier kann
man nicht ohne das einverständnis der
eltern machen was man möchte für mich
ist es eigentlich so dass ich gehen
möchte aber ich muss zuerst schauen wie
sich meine eltern entscheiden aber mein
herz sagt mir dass mich dieser familie
interessiert
doch bis zum heutigen tag haben ihre
eltern die erlaubnis zur heirat nicht
gegeben
und falls es mit angel nicht klappen
sollte will katharina eine andere
zweitfrau suchen der nächste akt in
diese unendlichen saga ist also gewiss